Speaker 1: The Republican primary field is
very quickly getting much more crowded, including
with two very interesting new entrants.
Mike Pence expected to announce he will run
against his own former president under whom
he served.
And Chris Christie is going to announce that
he is entering this race, which is very, very
interesting for other reasons, which I will
talk about in a moment.
We will start with Mike Pence.
Mike Pence reports.
NPR expected to announce 2024 run for president
on June 7th at an event in Des Moines.
According to a source familiar with the campaign.
I am sure that it will be an electric atmosphere
when Mike Pence makes this announcement.
No, it won't.
It will be quite the opposite, but it will
be an interesting announcement nonetheless.
And we'll talk about why in a moment.
NPR rates.
Pence has been signaling his plans for several
months, with several stops in early voting
states like New Hampshire and Iowa and the
announcement of a superPAC supporting his
bid.
Pence will join at least nine other Republicans
attempting to unseat Trump as the frontrunner
for the Republican nomination.
Now, what will Pence's campaign look like?
Because if you serve as vice president to
Trump and then you run against him, you can't
do the thing that Nikki Haley and Tim Scott
and others are doing where you don't criticize
Trump, Right?
If you're saying I disagree so much with the
guy I served under that I will run against
him.
You have to explain what your disagreements
are, I think.
NPR writes.
In the past several weeks, Pence's previewed
a campaign focused on returning the Republican
Party to traditional Republican themes like
expanding free markets, fiscal responsibility,
supporting American allies abroad and small
government.
He has made more pointed attacks on Trump,
his former running mate, by invoking his own
faith and family values and promising to respect
to respect the Constitution.
Here is an MSNBC NBC News report of the moment
when news of this broke.
Speaker 2: We have breaking news regarding
a new entry into the already crowded republican
race for president.
We told you last hour that on tuesday chris
christie was getting in.
Now on Wednesday, former vice president mike
pence.
NBC's john allen has the very latest.
He's breaking this story and joins me on the
phone.
John, what can you tell us?
I can tell you Mike Pence is in as of a week
from today.
He will be doing a video probably in the morning
and then a march speech in Des Moines, Iowa.
He was very focused on Iowa, as are a lot
of campaigns, as a place that they believe
is very hospitable to the former vice president
or because of its strong evangelical Republican
base.
So he'll be doing that speech sometime on
on the seventh.
And then there is going to be a town hall
later that night.
Okay.
Speaker 1: So that is the CNN town hall.
Last week, we we thought that Pence was going
in this direction because we knew CNN had
scheduled a Republican town hall with Pence.
And we said to ourselves, would they be doing
that if this guy was not going in the direction
of running?
So currently currently, Mike Pence is running
in fourth place.
We have the latest polling here.
As you can see, the big purple line at the
top is Trump at 53%.
The green line sort of in the middle of the
screen is DeSantis at 22.
So Trump 53, DeSantis 22.
Then it's Nikki Haley at about four and a
half percent.
And after Nikki Haley is Mike Pence at 3.8%
just ahead of Vivek Ramaswamy.
Will the announcement get some new support
for Mike Pence?
It might a couple of points worth.
I would I would expect.
But is this going to be a big shakeup to the
Republican primary?
I don't think so.
And part of it has to do with the fact that
many of the very people.
Who are not on the MAGA side.
Don't see Pence as the strongest alternative.
Partially because Pence, even though he may
be displeased with some of the way that Donald
Trump managed the presidency or whatever.
Pence is too close.
If you want to go anti MAGA, you probably
don't go with the MAGA vice president.
As much distance as Pence would like to put
between himself and Trump.
So the question is going to be for the MAGA
group, is there an alternative to Trump?
I doubt it would be Pence because many of
those MAGA people are mad that Pence quote
didn't send it back to the States in in 2020
to try to prevent Joe Biden from becoming
president in 2020 and 2021, even though he
really couldn't do that.
And so it's unlikely that they would say,
well, we really are MAGA, we want something
better, so we'll go with pence because they
see pence as an enemy, quite frankly, thanks
to the rhetoric from Donald Trump.
On the other hand, the anti MAGA people would
likely go with someone who was never affiliated
with Donald Trump.
So I don't exactly see how Mike Pence is going
to get anything out of this.
Mike Pence, as I believe in his early in his
early 6060s, Mike Pence, age a 63.
So I don't know if Pence is calculating that
if he wants to do this, he'd rather do it
at age 63 rather than 67 and maybe closer
to when he is more of a household name, maybe
fifth thinking by 2028.
Maybe people will have forgotten about me.
I don't know.
Again, I don't exactly know what Pence is
thinking.
I see the campaign as dead on arrival.
But let's now talk about a much more interesting
campaign than that of Mike Pence.
Let's talk
about Chris Christie.